vuelve rock in río uno de los festivales
de rock más importantes del mundo tras
tres años de pausa debido a la pandemia
del corno a virus estamos en la ciudad
olímpica de río de janeiro donde es 2016
aquí se celebraron los juegos olímpicos
ahora durante siete noches habrá
espectáculos hasta el 11 de septiembre
se prevé que 700 mil personas pasen aquí
para disfrutar de rock diversión y buena
música y quería saber qué representa
para usted el rock en río represento una
cultura desde 1985 y este año está
haciendo el mejor espectáculo de todos
contemplando 36 años de rock aquí mejor
porque porque creo que es uno de los
mejores espectáculos esperados de iron
maiden es una de las últimas giras que
está haciendo en el mundo y va a ser
aquí
[Música]
vine desde las ciudades y no estado de
matto grosso a 2500 kilómetros de río de
janeiro vine para disfrutar de este
evento de rock justamente porque leo ya
está loco por el grupo iron maiden y por
eso vine esta noche a honrar el evento
[Música]
este festival también representa una
importante fuente de ingresos para esta
ciudad el sector hotelero espera tener
todo ocupado en las siete noches en que
brazos estamos hablando de 52 mil
cuartos además se estrena este año un
escenario hecho íntegramente con acero
reciclado
104 metros de largo 175 toneladas aquí
además de iron maden habrá grandes
artistas como guns n'roses es dual y
para y coldplay
[Música]